you if you're a longtime viewer of the
show you knew this segment was coming
and not just because of that thing on
the right of the screen that says so
dick cheney's performance yesterday on
Meet the Press Jamie's use of both
evasion and intimidation was pretty
representative of the way that nearly
every CIA defender has avoided answering
the tough questions raised by the
Senate's report this is my favorite
Cheney moment from yesterday when Chuck
Todd asked him what his definition
torture is well torture to me Chuck is
an American citizen on his cell phone
making a last call was four young
daughters shortly before he burns to
death and the upper levels of the trade
center in new york city on 911 I don't
want to make light of the events of 911
and people dying but Vice President
Cheney was asked directly his for his
definition of torture and he told about
a terrorist it's a ridiculous it's a
ridiculous answer it's just totally
manipulative and it doesn't remotely
answer the question because if that is
literally his definition of torture it
means that American soldiers could draw
and quarter an unarmed combatant in some
other foreign country that would have to
consider torture this is he's citing one
example and it's not by definition a
definition I had another favorite moment
we've seen that was misdirection so
we're now we're to look at a different
kind of dick cheney move here which is
intimidation this is the response to
Chuck Todd got when we when we at when
he asked quote when you say
waterboarding a strut torture then why
did we prosecute Japanese soldiers it's
a really cheap shot Chuck to even try to
draw a parallel between the Japanese who
are prosecuted for war crimes after
world war two and what we did with
waterboarding three individuals all of
them are guilty and participating in the
911 attacks um what I enjoyed most about
that is first the cheap shot bang for
immediately right off the bat and then
the the UH the the Soviet flies in the
face of the evidence of the report which
he says it was only two three three
people who were waterboarded the port
report has many many more instances of
that all right one more another example
of evasion this time Chuck Todd as the
vice president if things like rectal
hydration meet the definition of torture
but Chuck now it's this was over and
above that was not something that was
done as part of the interrogation
program but you won't call it torture
wasn't torture in terms of it wasn't
part of program so it's part of the
program it's not torture there was no
torture as part of the program and if
something was maybe torture it wasn't
part of the program so you didn't
address it obviously this to me the
biggest weakness of the critics which is
there are plenty of things you can say
critical of the methodology in the
report and some of the mood music around
it but for people like the vice
president not to address the actual
issue here which is some things were
done by the United States government
that we're tortured if I have a if I
have a program that specifies certain
kinds of activities and then people who
are engaged in the program decided to go
off books and do all kinds of other
things that those things can still be
torture i think that's actually the
entire point of the Senate report so
here one of the big points of it so what
is Chaney's game here and what does he
try to do so you think people are just
gonna like believe this or is he just
kind of muddy up the atmosphere with a
lot of like I think he and Hayden and
the other people who came out they've
been working a plan for a long time and
they just decided they would go to their
strongest points play a lot of post 9-11
cards play a lot of games with the
interviewers and hope that in a live
television interview you're never going
to really big pin down if you want if
you're going to give non-responsive
responses it's a shame because there's a
lot to learn from the report even again
if you're critical for certain aspects
of it yeah absolutely